we have two received two proposals from
PPG in the first proposal we really gave
very clear feedback on what the key
concerns were which were related to
substantial undervaluation antitrust
issues risks and stakeholder related
matters and when we receive this second
proposal they had elected not to address
any of the issues we had there with
tangible and clear commitments that were
there and that is the reason why we see
no merit to engage with them but can you
really afford to ignore the views of a
quarter of your shareholders we have
actively reached out to a large number
of shareholders we've spoken to many of
them I speak to shareholders every day
we get a very calm and balanced response
and many of the shareholders are very
interested in the ox and obel plan in
how to unlock the value and make the
next steps that we will elaborate on on
the investors day on april nineteen do
you see any industrial logic in joining
forces with PPG I mean it would be a
greater scale to your business wouldn't
it it's true we have we are not as a
company against the consolidation in an
industry but we're talking here about
two leaders in the industry we're
talking about the top participants in
the industry that compete with each
other every day in many geographies
worldwide and therefore we see that
there will be substantial antitrust
issues related to this and that
certainly adds risks as well as value
leakage to the consideration but isn't
your problem though that you've failed
really to generate much in the way of
top-line growth last year your paint
sales were up just three percent your
coatings sales were static you need to
do something to grow this business done
to you yeah we have basically come out
of a period where we increase the
operational efficiency of the business
very significantly and we've embarked in
2016 on further operational excellence
again delivering a record year organic
growth in its initiation and you've seen
at the back end of the year that it's
been accelerating an acquisition that we
closed at the end of the year as well as
increased shareholder returns so in 2016
we went into the next phase of our
strategy we were well able to actually
deliver
growth and operational excellence as
well as additional shareholder returns
how many jobs do you think would be at
risk were PPG to succeed in taking you
over overall in mergers of this nature
you're talking thousands of jobs and
that will be of course worldwide and in
the UK obviously the UK still you are a
significant employer here have you able
to put a number on it at all we are
significantly invested in the UK we have
3,300 people working here we're
supporting through the pension funds in
excess of 60 thousand people in terms of
their pensions we've invested in the
country more than a hundred million
pounds in the northeast of the country
we've recently announced further
investment in the research and
development and that can certainly
potentially be threatened we've talked a
lot about cultural differences with PPG
the importance of Acts Annabel to the
Dutch economy how would you have felt in
2008 had I see I come up with similar
arguments against Akzo Nobel when you
were buying it we have looked at a
number of facets when we've looked at
the proposals a large number of them are
shareholder related a very important
aspect and there's also why I've been
reaching out so actively to them and a
number of them are stakeholder related
but they also have a shareholder impact
cultural differences in many large
mergers have been a reason to not be
able to create the value that was
originally intended and therefore
cultural differences that we perceive to
be large will also have an impact on
shareholder value